E aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo
bom com vocês hoje a gente está indo
academia do macgrego o que
tem uma academia de Muay Thai todo mundo
lá luta muay thai a gente vai fazer um
treino de box ele falou que lá tem um
saco de pancada muito bom e tá fazendo
sol
também meu pré-treino
já deixa o like aí então se você é da
Tropa do w não esquece de deixar o like
[Música]
eu tô de boa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vai ww vai ganhar
mais uma vez mais uma vez
galera isso aqui Geralmente
os lutadores fazem porque eu Geralmente
a galera pergunta o que que a gente faz
a banheira de gelo né que amanhã de gelo
para recuperação muscular
eles gostam de vir depois dos treinos
dá um mergulhozinho no mapa dá uma
recuperada eu confesso que eu pensei que
ia ser mais difícil mas não foi tão
difícil não
mas ele senta também o negócio é que
eles já tão pouco acostumado viu tipo
Depois de alguns segundos foi ele deve
ser
aí aproveita já logo
[Música]
me perguntaram qual era meu sonho
entrar
[Música]
fizemos
treino hoje teve esparrem
Mas vamos lá na água lá para fazer
recuperação e covery para fazer adiante
rolou numa água gelada tão quanto
ficamos lá tira uma mãozinha E aí vamos
fechar aqui na sauna agora para relaxar
Hoje não tem mais treino
vamos embora acompanha aí Fantástico
Mundo de Whindersson Nunes
[Música]